foreign
news out of Alabama tonight where
investigators said The Disappearance of
25 year old Carly Russell was all faked
she went missing
wait a second
that would mean women are liars and I've
never heard that before wait what
Honestly though this is the first time
I've seen a black chick get into this
game this is mostly a white women game
yeah but she's a pretty black woman
y'all been keeping up with this [__]
story no no okay give me the too long
didn't read for those who don't I I
covered a bunch of it last night so
[__] uh the homegirl called 9-1-1
while she was driving down the highway
and claimed that there was a
three-year-old walking down the side of
the highway with no pants on and just a
shirt okay
okay okay
at no point or during the call tried to
get out of the car and stop this little
child from walking down she decided that
it would be cool to like Drive behind
them right now I want to point out she
was the only person who reported a child
that was walking down the highway and
there were no reports of a missing child
at any time that day well thank God for
her then wow going the extra mile when
everyone else dropped the ball
so at some point during the call she
screams and the phone line goes dead
cops find her car uh the only thing
that's missing out of the car is her
phone
all right she shows up 48 hours later at
the family home where she lived
all right okay
does not want to speak to police
she is black
she is black yeah virgin I mean Virgie
the the you know they used to have
attitude and they used to say [__] them
okay go on so go on because honestly
quick run now because I mean I know some
of this but I'm I you know we cover up
we cover a lot of this [__] so I for
they all mixed together to me so she uh
she does a short interview like like
just a preliminary like yo where you
been [__] kind of thing uh cops [__]
off the next day the police chief comes
out and releases a statement on it of
all the evidence they had found so far
they have her on video like on the
highway okay driving down slow with
flashing lights there was no child in
view uh they know that she was Google
searching the movie Taken no no no no no
no no why do people do this dude I
watched so much True Crime and I'm like
why did you do that the two the two
things how to suffocate my baby from
your home PC like four hours before she
[__] did this she she called 9-1-1
she had Google searched how to take
money from a cash register without
getting caught
did she at least use a VPN no it would
no they no no
and she Google searched the movie Taken
which is a good movie
it's a good movie it's a good movie to
watch before you take take taken okay
before you get taken
so uh the I'm trying to remember what
the other things the police chief said
that was really the the his his [__]
press conference was literally like
[__] we know you did it for like 20
minutes
on the interstate investigators say she
now admits to making the whole thing up
she admitted
Russell returned to her family's home in
Hoover Alabama two days after her
disappearance and a massive surge this
afternoon Hoover's police the one thing
the other thing I didn't know about this
story is that now she is claiming that
it was mental illness
oh yeah that was the thing she said that
she initially told police that uh she
was outside of her car and some guy came
up to her like out from the woods and
grabbed her ass and threw her in
um threw her in a tractor trailer they
did uh they did that Kurt Russell movie
the [__] uh the the one where his
wife oh yeah uh Joyride or whatever yeah
whatever that they did that she did that
she did she did a Kurt Russell
by the way this can I point out
something I'm reading this story too and
there's a little detail that's bothering
me here
investigators with help from the Secret
Service analyzed wrestle cell phone for
the days leading up yeah I noticed that
well why the Secret Service oh because
they thought they had another black a
black woman that had been kidnapped yeah
but even if they did that's not in that
she wasn't counterfeiting money or
trying to kill the president so why is
this and that's in the those are the two
things yeah that's it no because uh you
know the Biden Administration secret
service has a vested interest in this
story for some reason
huh
kind of weird huh okay I just sent you
the family which was the family's uh
interview right after on today right
after she came home that like the next
morning and then I sent you the police
update also merch your audio levels are
fine your gain is a little hot
moment only when you're lost eyes on her
again all right which is always what is
it like
to me I mean okay hold on this okay this
is the family uh okay this family you
all first laid eyes on her again watch
the Dad's face during this interview so
this interview is from seven days okay
me
so much
morning and
with NBC News the parents of 25 year old
Carly Russell are speaking out
describing the moment their daughter
appeared on their doorstep after being
missing for more than 48 hours hamers
this is a question that I'm going to ask
you because this is important because
this is the Secret Service is involved
so would you
uh uh she's a little crazy man oh no no
okay let's do this let's play this game
forget the fake I think we have to say
this out loud forget to fake kidnapping
I mean I know I've seen good pictures
and I've seen bad pictures so it's it's
this chick seems to have some wildly uh
fluctuating let me so let me answer that
question yes if merch was drunk enough
right is that a good answer like yes
depending how drunk you are maybe he can
lie about it but we have the same taste
in black women and mine is yes if I was
drunk enough yeah but what happened with
Mercer's Marshall lying and be like I
would never but then they kept the
Secret Service investor gets in this
video of him clearly picking her up at a
bar
it's not me it says look we have a lip
right it's not me that was the
three-year-old baby
yeah she's kind of is a black moped we
actually have a lip reader here being
the surveillance footage and we clearly
hear you saying hey baby girl what's up
baby girl
thing for more than 48 hours what did
you do when you saw her we laughed
tried to harvest best we could but I had
to stand back she got real fat
so real hard
because she was not in a good State what
a broken man that father is
we of course she's not in a good State
this is what Alabama right
you can stand back and let medical
professionals work with her oh yeah
you're right the dad's like I can see
what you're saying Virgie um
he knows it's all [__]
look at his eyes holy [__] Bro body
language expert would have a field day
with him look at it she knows I think
they knew she was lying already like not
because they had their suspicions but
because she told them
well because she's probably a typical
like nobody just does this like right
she's done some deceptive weird [__] in
the past
that [__] is a day-to-day problem
yeah yeah
and also and and she's also probably
somebody who who's probably fake getting
pregnant just to get abortion money
dude she she's like [__] 25 and she
lives with her parents
last Thursday police say Carly called
9-1-1 to report a toddler walking alone
on the interstate she pulled over while
on the phone with a family member who
described hearing Carly scream her
vehicle's unlocked running all her
personal belongings except for her phone
on the scene police found no sign of
Carly or a child and they say no
children were reported as missing during
that time period yeah that was the
actual footage of her car and like
stopping was there a child around no but
okay but what what would her what would
her motivation be to do that but no I
don't I know I don't want to hear you
because she's crazy but like really what
would her motivation be attention my
okay yeah my um theory on it is because
like she her Google searches were about
like committing crimes and [__] what
honestly yeah about the the how to rob a
[__] cashier or cash register or not
get caught and [__] like that uh someone
doesn't play GTA yeah so I I honestly
think that this was her Alibi and she
was gonna go like rob a store or some
[__] and it didn't work Alibi is also
the name of her kid
Russell running back University Alabama
he and he had a heart attack
oh no Aquarius Marquis
University
calls and texts from people who
maliciously lied to us I just didn't
know
people could be so evil authorities have
not indicated where Carly was during the
48 Hours she was missing or what
happened her parents declined to share
what their daughter told them citing the
ongoing investigation so she did tell
them early on that it was a lie that's
why the dad was having that yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and can you tell me what
happened Saturday night did you just get
a knock at the door anything leading to
to the chase itself we we didn't know
because our neighbors are Hispanic and
they were watching sabado higante
so it was really really loud so we
couldn't hear it we can't it's kind of a
big tradition here you watch it every
week and the husband's like some of the
women on that show they'd be fine though
discuss that but they say speculation
about the circumstances surrounding
Carly's disappearance here's the problem
[__]
and I mean with no due respect
here's the problem [__] you do this
to yourselves because all you [__]
are so much into True Crime that every
[__] with free time is now a detective
so you can't lie anymore and it's not
going to be men they're going to call
you up because honestly when women talk
we ignore you but other women no it's
true but but other women are like all
cereal and all these True Crime shows
and podcasts so they all think they're
gonna crack a crime so they're the ones
who'll be like oh something actually
doesn't add up women you've created a
monster and because of that it's made it
impossible for you to lie
are only making things worse she's
having to deal with the trauma of people
just making completely false allegations
about her her fear but she lied but not
the the trauma of the thing that she
said happened okay hold on hold on she
didn't lie she just didn't tell the
truth that's what lying is that's
literally but lying is the definition of
lying
the public to let the investigation play
out pretty much the resident expert on
Deception here should probably take his
lead an abductor her mother he's like
morph asking to read a brief message to
the public Carly has given detectives
her statement
so that they can continue to pursue her
abductor do you believe that there's an
abduction this is seven days ago then
she came out
I hate women still out there
absolutely
absolutely NBC News has reached out to
the Hoover Police Department to ask
whether they're looking for an
individual involved police have just
said they're following up on all
information provided by Carly and for
some reason the Secret Service is
involved yeah it's so [__] odd man I
just caught that in the article and I'm
like why were the Secret Service be
involved when I talked to you all on
Saturday you also said your daughter is
a fighter and she would find a way back
to you oh no she would always get into
fights in school I was gonna say yeah
always fighting people at bars
she's a black woman I know she's a
fighter that [__] is taking off her
earrings and said what are you gonna do
about it many times he's a fighter yeah
she's a black woman that's her Baseline
setting yeah [__] seriously they come
out of factory like that yeah it's her
default factory settings if you push the
little button in the back of her skull
and she resets it just she just defaults
to volume was that a phrenology joke
it was a soft reset button and a
phrenology joke wow high-tech phonology
joke I thought it flop I thought it was
a Treehouse of Horror joke oh okay look
all of them work all right oh here's the
thing you have her set on evil
the problem is we just have to wait for
Elon to give us neuro Lincoln and we
just flip turn everybody into the white
setting no no no no he he he's too busy
making changing the logo a logo that's
[__] traditional that everybody knows
into just the letter X and now Marsh I'm
sure you're seeing your tabs how
terrible Twitter looks in your in your
Google Chrome tabs I can't find it
because it looks like a [__] offshore
gambling site logo on top
yeah it doesn't look great
and the functionality like the UI is all
weird now yeah
she did she found her way back to us
however
we can't discuss the details of that but
they say one thing is clear do you
believe she was fighting for her life
she definitely there were moments when
she physically had to fight for her life
and there were moments when she had to
mentally fight for her life like in the
movie Taken
like like the movie
I'm doing field research I'm watching
all the Takens taking one taking two
taking three and even read the movie
script for taken four taken for granted
you've taken full granted
no I do like the fact that we all knew
this [__] was full of [__] that is she
she did this and she disappeared and the
whole search was for her not for the
baby yeah because the baby didn't the
baby never existed yeah yeah okay fine
let's go find this [__]
but she made it back to you she made it
back
yeah she did make it back all right
that's really funny that now that you've
pointed out that there's no mention in
this interview about the child that she
was supposedly missing hold on but did
you see this this before it came out
watch it today people have fake even
though they know it's fake watch what
they had to do watch why don't you come
back to them yeah she did make it back
all right Priscilla so yeah she did make
it back well Brave investigators are
obviously busy on this case what are
they looking into the case what's what
case what's the mystery here what's the
big [__] scoop the case against her
that they're gonna bring in false
reporting and then they're probably not
going to either no they're not
no you know what you're probably right
they're not black woman
yep because probably the same Secret
Service is telling them Shut the [__] up
you should shut up don't push sorry
remember when they tried that with Jesse
smallett when they were like yeah we're
not gonna do any charges and the entire
country was like the [__] you aren't
you [__] better uh here's a little
bit more in itals are coming to light in
the mysterious disappearance of an
Alabama woman apparently it was all a
hoax that is according to a statement
released by an attorney on behalf of
Carly Russell the same attorney
that she was fighting for her life yeah
well attorneys are liars
toddler on the side of a highway before
Vanishing Russell's claim prompted a
massive search only for her to return
Days Later NBC's Sam Brock has more on
this shocking revelation
a stunning public confession in the
mysterious disappearance of Carly
Russell so here's what happened and this
is hilarious because these people always
do this to themselves and what I mean
I'm not talking specifically of black
people I'm talking specifically of like
the gay ass woke people right just not
too long ago when Nina Turner and all
those [__] black exploitation people
on [__] Twitter were like oh joy Reed
remember recently we put a couple months
ago merch majority was like if a black
girl's missing nobody cares I know I
made her sound more like Aunt Jemima but
that's what she sounds in my head and
then they go so now what happens is a
black girl godsmith goes missing
everybody cares they all like what
happened and then she was lying
yeah
so this is why we don't pay attention
anymore
[__] Christ it's like it's like every
time they find a [__] hate crime or a
synagogue with a swastika on it all of a
sudden you can find a guy who [__]
looks like pessie with stained hand
that's what I mean no that stink as I
was trying to wipe it off the Russell
there was no never anything bad happens
now my immediate reaction is maybe
you're doing this to yourself fake until
proven gay yes that's how we roll around
here napping Hoover's police chief
reading a statement on Monday provided
by Russell's attorney on behalf of the
25 year old nursing student my client
did not see a baby on the side of the
road
it might have been some sort of raccoon
or armadillo
that was dressed wearing a child's shirt
client did not leave the Hoover area but
this was a single act done by herself
for days the investigation captured
national attention but skepticism
quickly grew when police were unable to
verify her story where do you think she
went and how would you characterize what
happened here so this is okay this is
what you were talking about Virgie right
where the the cops like this is all
[__] the hundred dollar question
earlier this month I also like how he
said it's a hundred dollar question yeah
it's well it's Alabama
you know they don't have a lot of money
there but missing for just over I know
we've driven through the roads of
Alabama they're [__] terrible yeah 48
hours after their highways one large
pothole only 9-1-1 to report a toddler
walking alone on the interstate hi I am
on Interstate 459 and there is a kid
that's walking by theirselves in her
initial statement to police Russell
claimed that she was abducted by him
yeah police um they don't be a kid done
walking down the street by them theyself
and they're all walking and [__] I mean
she doesn't sound like [__] song in
herself Jesus Yosemite Sam more with
orange hair and a woman who brought her
to a home forced her to undress and took
nude photos of her nice
I could say that it never happened it
never happened so we are only say that
can we see the here's the thing and I'm
already well in a bet that there's nude
photos of you out there man right so if
it's fake revenge porn it was still
illegal for us to see it I don't know
how it works
yeah what if I just do AI generated porn
with your likeness
the investigation police say they found
no evidence of an abandoned toddler also
detailing internet searches made by
Russell shortly before the incident
including
wildly fluctuate yes like she's very
good at Deception in photographs because
there's a bunch of photos where she's
like looked great and then any natural
photo you're like oof but only in
photograph she's terrible at Deception
with everything else obviously yeah yeah
not good at inventing made-up children
I forgot about that one one of the other
things she Google searched was if I call
if if you call in an amber alert will
they make you pay for it
bro and here's the thing if anybody got
woken up in the middle of the night
because this bit they sent out an Amber
Alert in Alabama she should get the
electric chair because there is nothing
worse than being woken up to
[__] off I turn that off every chance I
get let the kids die I don't care I am
not doing it
bus ticket from Birmingham to Nashville
in the 2008 oh you woke me up at four in
the morning to tell me that a dad was
done apologize for directions to this
community we asked for you yeah the
merch always points that out whenever
it's like a kidnap but the kidnapper as
a kid same last name it's like oh so
it's the dad that just wanted to see the
kid yeah it's custodial interference
stop wait stop [__] abusing the Amber
Alert system oh I hate getting it you
hit an Amber you're woke yeah you're
woken up you look at the Amber Alert
system and it's just like oh yeah okay
just go back to Dad yeah because it's
always like I don't mind getting an
amber alert that wakes me up if all
right four in the morning this little
girl in my neighborhood just got yanked
out of a window at night okay yeah I I
hey you know what fine give me a quick
alert boom boom bing tell me what car to
look for I'll even go outside and smoke
a cigarette you woke me up anyway uh but
you know and it's like oh the dad was
mad because they changed his visitation
schedule and I'm like okay so now we're
now we're launching an entire alert
system and we've got everyone on a high
alert over this relax dude he's not
gonna unless he has a history of abuse
he's not gonna murder this kid he
probably said you know what [__] you you
[__] [__] I'm taking this [__]
kid and we're having our goddamn weekend
at the beach you're not [__] stopping
me that's all it was yep
come back Monday he'll cool he'll cool
off we'll come back with the kid
everything will be fine
every Amber Alert ever is Sarah Michaels
traveling with Douglas Michaels
exactly and it's always the dates always
the dates always match up to you know
Sarah Michaels age eight seen with uh
you know Stephen Michaels age 30 and
you're like see this is all lining up
yeah we know what happened clearly the
dad yeah
she addresses her issues or it's even
funnier when the mom takes the kid and
runs and it's like that's even less
menacing like whenever it's the mother
that grabs the kid and is like I'm
taking my head it's like all right but
it's the Mom calm down we know exactly
what's happening